lots of big changes coming to the David
Pakman show over the next few weeks I
figured this is a good time as any to
let people know what's going on I've
noticed that people often get very very
upset when anything is different and we
haven't been clear and upfront about it
so here's what's going on next week we
are going to have sitting next to me
right over there a guest host co-hosting
with me and that will be Jen briny of
the Congressional Dish podcast and this
is of course unless something radical
changes in the next 48 hours she is
going to be here with me we are going to
co-host on Monday Tuesday I will be
traveling as I do every six months to
the mass torts made perfect conference
in Las Vegas with our friend Mike
Papantonio from Rio Fire Sam cedar Baron
Cousins the whole crew is going to be
there and on Tuesday I will be sitting
on a plane most of the day so Jen Brian
II instead of sitting over in that seat
is going to be sitting in this seat and
will actually be guest hosting the
entire show and the bonus show on
Tuesday and then the rest of next week
I'll be coming to you from Las Vegas
Nevada
I predict a very very dry and warm
temperatures which could affect the show
I guess hopefully not at all but we'll
just be doing the show from Las Vegas
for the rest of the week and then the
following week the david pakman show
will be on what we call spring break
although I hesitate to call it that
because it does sound very very childish
we will be on a planned vacation I guess
is a better way of saying it and this
relates to the fact that we have now
surpassed the 10% mark we have obtained
sixty-four new financial supporters out
of our target of 500 and the goal will
allow us once we reach that goal of 500
new financial supporters will be able to
hire additional staff so that when we
have one of these planned breaks staff
can stagger vacations so that we can
continue doing new shows during the
breaks and also extend each show by 10%
by getting rid of some advertising so
hopefully I can't say for sure but
hopefully this will be the last time
that we actually are off during a
vacation because we will have reached
the five
new supporters three ways that you can
contribute to that 500 number number one
you can become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership monthly
yearly your choice you can use the
coupon code vote soon 18 to save 40%
option number two you can become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show even a dollar a month contribution
gets you on that list of 500 new
supporters and gets us closer to our
goal and number three you can become a
youtube sponsor we are part of the
YouTube sponsorship beta you'll see a
button in blue text on the YouTube
channel home page and on most of our
video pages which you can click and for
$4.99 a month you become a youtube
sponsor which has its own really great
set of benefits we are at sixty four the
goal is 500 I hope you'll participate
and we've got a great program planned
for you today